two by the blood of the lamb by the
blood of the lamb
welcome to the history podcast of the
lamb of god
god we are watching these clips of uh
welcome to the hp podcast oh yeah we're
back in our basement because the corner
is so out of control you know
i feel like another lockdown is imminent
and anyway i just felt like it wasn't
safe for everybody to be in that small
confined
room with the way things are getting so
i was very sad
i'm not happy that we're all back in our
home
because i really like being there with
everybody in the office but here we are
you know and we got the guys on zoom
yeah say hi everybody we got we got
whatever
we've got dan the wizard we finally see
dan's bedroom dan who's got
a or is this a false background
you've got a lot of stuff on that
dresser i got to tell you
uh a little bit a dabble dabble slapping
a basement
a slap at the base and um we've got
uh zach who is at
uh woodstock yes i uh i'm at woodstock
right now
was that the height of music zack
woodstock um
yeah it also 69 was a weird year it kind
of
was a good transition in the 70s 69
that's the year huh
yeah nice
do you like the position 69
[Laughter]
yes you do yeah i find it a little
overwhelming
yeah it's kind of a gimmick it's not a
real sexual position i feel like
well i mean what do you mean by that
well because like
it's kind of hard to i feel like
it's kind of hard to give and receive
pleasure it's a lot going on i feel like
because you can't focus entirely on one
task
that that that's very true that's my
problem with the 69 dan you have um
you have a counterpoint i see dan
shaking his head
i mean you know if you got the skills i
mean it just sounds like you're lacking
in some
some practice i don't know did you ever
try that reverse 69
i don't know isn't that a normal kissing
what's the reverse 69.
it's when the the guys on top and then
the girl's on bottom
and you just [ __ ] just you just
destroy her face what does he mean what
does that mean
exactly that's exactly what it is have
you tried that zach
uh no i've tried that that's what dan
does that's why he likes it so much
suffocating his poor girlfriend um
ian we have yeah let's see you doesn't
want to comment and that's fair enough
hi guys hello ian your hair is growing
i know i got a mullet going on
uh let's scan there i need to go out i
need to go
in quarantine but i don't want to go
deal with the barber yeah i hate i'm
very barber at first
it's so intimate you have to talk with
them yeah i don't like talking to the
barber i sit there and silence
i feel like they always want to talk to
me and i agree i feel like it's even
worse for women but maybe i'm just wrong
but i feel like they're expected to
chitchat well
i think it depends if you have a female
usually yes because i have a female
usually it's a female cutting my hair
too and they want
they want a chit chat you know
i'd imagine they must get i mean that's
what they're expected to do is talk to
you but
i'd imagine five six hours in
they would prefer us to just shut the
hell up
then why don't they just shut up and let
me sit there silently i think because
that's what
that's kind of goes hand in hand that's
your thing that's the that's the
question i hate the most how's your day
it's like how do you really want me to
answer that it's like
whatever i had to drive here and it's
fine yeah park
and it's fine how's your day oh
good anything new going on
yeah any plans for the weekend bro
don't ask me what i do for a living
that's like the oh
i hate that question yeah i always i've
tried so many different directions like
um i said that i'm just an editor even
though i'm not
you you don't want to start a
conversation yeah you're trying to find
the answer that's
that has the least amount of following
inquiries yeah but there is al
always following questions like no
matter what you're saying
say i'm a guard i'm a garbage man
they'll be like oh really
what area okay let me try let me find
what what can i
answer that will give the loose inquiry
um
i'm a telemarketer oh wow
how long have you been doing that see i
that's the fight it's like you know
who cares but telemarketer the job sucks
well what products do you sell it's like
they're trying to follow your bluff hang
on
um i'm a uh
i'm a dentist so you can ask about that
what the [ __ ] you gonna ask about that
you know wow
it's like really how old are you wow
what's your favorite tooth yeah nobody's
gonna ask about your favorite tooth so i
think that's a pretty good answer
well you gotta worry about for where did
you go to dental school oh
oh you think they would ask that yeah
definitely it'd be like uh
yeah that's a i see yeah you don't want
to get into that it's like whatever you
think it kind of gets worse
you don't expect it can i tell you about
a story in college i was sitting there
working
minding my own business i was writing an
essay or something in the college
library
and i would and i just didn't really
want to be bothered okay this is the
only time i've ever done this in my life
and some guy who there's like there's
this guy who goes to
like
um he's like this older guy
and he was like a teacher's aide or
something and
i don't know if he had like i don't know
what it was
but he just wouldn't he wouldn't see
this guy that would come up to you and
just not stop talking
i wasn't friends with him i was barely
even acquainted with the guy
but he'll just come up to you and he
won't stop
right and i said to him like almost
immediately because i saw where it was
going i was like
i was like listen i don't really want to
have a conversation right now
and um and then well i immediately felt
bad yeah
and he you could tell that he
immediately was like super
crushed yeah but he was like okay no
problem i didn't want to bother you and
he walks off
but you have to you have to understand
that like
i didn't have a lot of time
so the question is is that something you
can tell barbara is that something you
know it's um
i don't really feel like having a
conversation right now my worst one was
actually the last one that i had with a
barber because since then i only
let your mom cut my hair and it was this
lady
and she kept asking me what do i do and
i was trying to do like the video
production angle because
you don't want to go into like we have a
youtube channel no
so i was just doing like i do video
production
and um she kept trying to ask questions
and i tried to give like this one word
answers to kind of like
wrap it up and then there's this new
thing i guess
with barbers they really want to build
up their instagram accounts
and they a lot of times will take photos
of like before and after
and things like that and so she was
starting to go
in that direction and i was on my phone
because
that's another way to like not socialize
you're like
on your phone and so she was like what's
your instagram account i can tag you
and when we're done i can put up a
picture and i can tag you
was the haircut that magnificent that
she needed to post no i hated it
it was not was an expensive haircut no
just regular ever
like i just walked into a place regular
price
average haircut um
so then it got really awkward because
she already knew my name
and she was asking me for my instagram
account i'm not on instagram
i was already on my phone though so she
saw that i was on instagram
so i had to tell her my instagram
account yeah and then
she saw the followers and i could see on
her face like
wait the will started turning like what
do you do
like i feel like she started to think
that i'm actually a porn star
because i told her that i do
because i told her that i do video
production and i didn't want to go into
detail so she's like why
and i have followers you know that's
like the first time
and i ended up feeling so weird did she
say anything
no i feel like she kind of got the idea
that i don't want to talk about it
because yeah it's really interesting
it was super weird
i don't know maybe that's a good answer
to get them to stop talking
what do you do what do i do for a living
baby i do what about like i do super
just give them all the info up front i
do i do gangbang
yeah i do uh on black dog i do piss porn
have you heard of your favorite.com yeah
yeah i was gonna say get really like i
do uh sado masochistic
uh
how long have you been doing that yeah
well
well we don't last long in this business
honey how many guys at a time
yeah you think someone would ask that i
don't know they would they'll find the
questions
those barbers know what's your favorite
what's the biggest dick you've taken
[Laughter]
what about uh my uh
my mom's a hair stylist so i have to ask
her what the
thing is that my mom makes her back off
i'm gonna ask my mom that
that's a really good that just see we
can provide useful information to people
but this isn't even about being like a a
seedless celebrity this is about being
like even when i was just doing
marketing i i never wanted to
i just didn't want to have a
conversation see what i hate is
conversations
that are completely substanceless that
you'll walk out of and forget
and then you have and then like having
the same conversation with the next
barber every time it's just
[ __ ] hate it drives me crazy i hate
when they do it at the
grocery stores like oh dude you know we
don't have time
you know i'm here for like two minutes
right well they tell the cashiers be
friendly
we want chit chat they're like
tchotchkes remember that from
office space i think trader joe's is the
tchotchkes of the grocery world
make sure to say to do chit chat that's
your day going
bro listen that was not the time for a
conversation
hot out huh you got plans for tonight
they
literally asked that it's like what what
is your intention there
are you trying to find something to do
no i just had a big fight with my
husband
um really don't want to go back home
like why did you want me to start
pouring my heart out
yeah then all of a sudden they're done
like all right move it along
okay everybody in your ass all right get
the [ __ ] out didn't care
in the first place anyway thanks to rich
for sponsoring this episode
um am i the only one that has a are we
the only do you guys have problems with
small talk
uh yeah no i i yes this is very
relatable
okay yeah i feel like you guys sometimes
i'll start small talk with like
at the grocery store you will you start
it well
of course you're the person that we're
complaining about yeah
i'm very interested by people in their
story oh
zach you have 30 seconds with them what
story
i don't know maybe i don't anything to
brighten someone's day up i don't know
so maybe you're not brightening their
day maybe you're just maybe they're like
[ __ ]
so wait what would you ask someone at a
cashier at a grocery store
like how's your day oh
how's the fruit aisle first fresh ripe
so how's your day going i don't know
traffic on the way into work today
like i was i was at the grocery store
the other day and the woman that was
you know scanning my stuff she looked
like she was just in a bad mood and
i don't know i tried to so you went let
me
talk to her really good and it did she
she actually like it made her happy just
like this
so tell me about that give me an
in-depth conversation
that you had with her just i i don't
i'm like so like how's your day going
you know she's like oh you know it's
pretty rough
and then she's like there was this like
this lull and i'm like
yeah it's pretty hot outside
it got a little little that ruined her
day
it seemed like it it put a smile on it
so she
so what happened was she she opened the
door to a real conversation to you
and you didn't take it you said wow it's
hot outside
well i you could have probed a little
deeper
i'm just trying to be nice that's all i
was doing yeah
you said it's hot outside what did she
say yep
yep wow was there anything scorcher was
there did you say yep
with a p he's like and i'm like and i'm
like yeah you know and then i brought up
like how heat kills the virus and she's
like i hope it's killing something
tell me everything kills this kills this
conversation
maybe a minute man i am so envious of
you zack
i wish i could be more like you
you think that brand or day i i hope it
did yeah
me too i do i'm being too critical but
would somebody with somebody saying that
to you brighten your day maybe that's
maybe that's the secret i think so yeah
i think it would that's sweet so there
are there's like different people
yeah in the world
right not everyone is like you i guess
the fact that i'm like you makes us
think that everybody is like that
no i know zach zach is a very sweet kind
zach is pure heart he's very pure thank
you thank you golden boy yeah your heart
pure 69 you know
if you're 69 baby apparently not only
people but not on top
or reverse you're you're sensitive 96
96
reverse 96 oh boy
i never forget my friend uh
you know him you probably heard the
story he he referred to this girl he's
like this super sensitive social justice
warrior
and then he goes yeah this is in college
he goes uh
he just said nowhere he goes ah he sees
a cute girl and he goes
i'd like to put i'd like to do push-ups
on her face
i was like what though
you've heard anything like that in your
life i like to do push-ups on her face
just like straight up no
no i do not support that message
um well
shout out to the barbers out there i
guess the the
i guess the best barbers read the room
um you know
because being a barber being a barber's
like being a bartender you gotta kind of
you know
you got um work it you gotta listen
you're a therapist you're that you're
the uh corner store
therapist everybody got therapist
anyway today we are sponsored by ridge
as i mentioned spongebob
teddy fresh ex sponge bob the epic
collaboration that sold out last time
in about five minutes it was all gone by
popular demand
the restock is back july
15th exclusively at teddyfresh.com
these will not be on zoomies this is
exclusively teddy fresh
we have and including new limited
edition colors this is your last
chance to get this beautiful collection
so bye now bye now or
be forever regretful
okay guys has anyone else seen dark i've
been watching that on netflix and it's
like
insanely good dark anybody
i was gonna watch with you and i end up
falling asleep every night
and anything has been staying up all
night every day of the week
of the last week i'm sorry i didn't
realize
i didn't realize we were going to be
attacking ethan today
i'm not really attacking you actually a
compliment to the show
i can actually i just can't um i'm just
a night person i just i have a really
hard time going to bed before too like
even when i've i've been waking up early
i'm just really sleep deprived because
this week i've been waking up early but
i still can't go to bed before too and
it's really a problem for me more than
two
yeah i'm gonna sleep later than two yes
i probably went to bed at like
around three last night maybe even later
3 30 probably um
how do you feel about the nobody's seen
dark
i have not you told me about it i want
to check it out but it's really good
in the dark on that one
hang on where's my sound bites
garbage garbage garbage
uh ela sorry i cut you off what were you
saying
how do you did you get used to watching
it with subtitles yeah totally
for some reason it doesn't like it
autoplays and
dub when you first put the show on and
it's like oh my god i thought it was the
worst show ever
and then we realized wait it's dumb yeah
why why would anyone even watch a dub
show can we talk about that
i don't know i'm i'm sub gang for life
it's
their subtitle option i'm definitely
doing that
especially on like not an anime like
anime makes sense
that's different but like real people
dub
anime dub [ __ ] rules let's get that
straight
um debatable but it's okay
some are really good some are some are
really good i agree with you like
for example full metal alchemist right
don't hate yeah hater yeah that one
actually is pretty good
but um but film dub is crazy [ __ ]
anyway yeah the dub was really hard to
watch either you want to look at some
bad tattoos yes great
so we've been saving these up you know
that we always do this segment don't
look yet yellow
i had bad tattoos here i'm gonna cover
this don't you see it
and uh this all started of course with
ben affleck's
backpack too that ila said was the worst
tattoo she's ever seen
so since then we've been on a mission to
find
a tattoo worse than ben affleck's back
yeah
today with jacked jack
from the nightmare or or was it called
chris yeah
jacked jack now what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you guys
why would you tattoo that it's so it's
not even funny it's weird
the details are impressive though like
there's a lot of small details in there
they're pretty impressive
yeah like jack jack has tattoos it's
tattoo
ception and he's got pubic hairs bro oh
no
he's got pubes going down to his uh
penis
he's jacked jack don't hate now is this
a female or male's leg
i would say a female you think she jerks
off to that
yeah she goes like this she looks back
at her leg
interesting oh so how do you rate this
worse than
well we've already went over that you
know there's different factors so it's
kind of hard but
i think this game should just be less
worse than worse than ben affleck
really but but these are regular people
and ben affleck is ben affleck
so so on a scale of although actually we
found out that we thought it was
lying about it being a realtor too and
then we found out that was a fake story
so he's gained credit since then okay
how do we measure story has changed
we need like we need a standardized way
of
harming the meter has changed because
when we thought that he lied about his
tattoo
that put it like up here yeah now we
found out he was just trolling paparazzi
which is pretty
great so he's he's got a lot of street
credit back
okay so how do we measure these so i
think this is worse than ben
yeah but we need something that's bad we
need something that like
holds that high bar we had what were the
worst ones that we picked
there was like the dude with the belly
button that was like the giant cows
[ __ ]
yeah it's like flying yeah that one was
rough i mean i don't know why you would
do that to your body
okay is this worse than cow hole we
called it well and i should say this
won't be helpful because it's kind of
the finale of this segment and i i don't
want to give any spoilers but there
there is potentially a new king in this
batch that's going to uh
surpass just give it a scale one being
the like worst thing you've ever seen
like if this was on somebody you would
disassociate from knowing that
okay and 10 being like that's a really
good idea
okay so what would you rate this so one
is like i gotta
unfriend you yeah okay um
if i knew this girl personally and like
i mean
like a a three is like that's a [ __ ]
horrible tattoo
a one is like you have a swastika on
your forehead yeah
okay and this is a three okay great
so this is cool this is kobe bryant
you know i just feel bad because
obviously it was made in earnest
yeah and but obviously just not by a
good artist
so i don't it looks like he's hanging
look like what's
going on under the rim it looks like i
mean
but i forget that i can look here now um
this
uh the intention is good yeah
the execution is bad so it's more about
like i would fire the two artists but
um it's not that bad okay
this one says um i
that's his name it's blanked out i'm
getting a
tattoo voluntarily on january 3rd 2019
so i can earn my wife's trust back for
the pain and suffering i've caused in
our marriage i am
a liar cheater manipulator deceiver or
prostitute lover
dishonest and disrespectful
if i was the wife i would break up with
this guy but i have a feeling the wife
wrote this made him do that you're right
oh no i don't think so
i one trillion percent think the wife
made him do that and disagree with you
wait what do you mean ella oh you think
that he just did this on his own to try
and get her back
kind of thing yeah well that i don't
know which one's worse
that's worse
oh my god i was assuming what ethan said
that that she
told him he's got to do this because
it's written like it's written like an
ultimatum
right no way jose
but he he also says so i can earn my i
don't know it's a tough call what do you
two think uh zach and ian
dead mother loving heir
i think he he did it to try and win his
wife back
well yeah yeah i think it was a
hail mary desperate play at the end of
the game yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah what kind of wife would
make you do that you already lost a
crazy one
like no he's crazy read all the stuff
he's done he lied he cheated he
manipulated
yeah he's the crazy one
did he misspell deceive
i before e except after c i think he
misspelled deceiver
oh you're right he spelled the scenery
see the wife would not misspell dude you
misspelled deceiver you [ __ ]
so is it like same level as a swastika
no so it's a nine no you know but i
would rate this
it's nine nine nine or two
sorry two yeah two is bad a two i was
rated too
this guy is clearly unstable i mean god
damn this guy is
liable to do anything oh so
this one reads the sweetest girl i ever
kissed was another man's wife
my mother
the sweetest girl i ever kissed was
another man's
wife my mother
so like i understand what he's going for
but that's just going to be a no for me
dog
well it's weird he you can't refer to
your mother as a girl
yeah it's [ __ ] that's weird bro there's
some weird vibes off this one
forever yeah moving on i mean that that
one's not
that's like a four yeah so this one this
one's actually really funny
because this one with tattooed white
lives matter but the
the comment from john b's she got the
mcdonald's fun
is so [ __ ] so fun
white lives matter oh yeah yeah
i mean that's like a one for me yeah
that's a one
that said this zone that's definitely a
one don't engage
like oh sh that's like if she's on this
side of the
crosswalk i'm i'm crossing the street to
the other side
right that's a one that's definitely a
one now
this you have the scorpion king drake it
was a really good execution but
terrible yeah terrible thing to have on
your thigh
yeah but again i would i would give that
like a i would even give that a five
more
you know shoe okay this guy tattooed a
shoe on his foot and i don't understand
why
are you trying to disgust me he's just
trying to cruise around without a shoe i
don't get the purpose
this dude tattooed a shoe he loves
jordan so much
is that what he just loves his jordans
that's the worst tattoo ever wow
although somehow it's not a one
because it's not hateful yeah but it's a
two
yeah it's a god that must have hurt
is this what you assumed would be the
worst one dan
um yeah i i think so wait for me that's
the worst
no but here there's like a stain i guess
yeah it's like shading
because you know sometimes you get like
your sneakers get dirty
i think it's meant to be shade what how
was that shade this whole there's like a
whole dark blotch here
like it's leather so i think they were
trying to go super realistic like a
concealer
yeah but that looks way better than this
that just looks like
like he spilled milkshake on his shoes
you like his i think this guy's got
stains on his shoes do you like his
toenails
i was literally noticing the toenail
actually
yeah should have tattooed over those and
then finally
or not finally you like heaven don't you
mommy
march 10th oh my god 1973 to march 14
2019 rest in peace
incidentally you can also tell he has a
cross on his back so he's a religious
man
you like heaven don't you mommy
what why would you do that
that's a one that's a one i'd be like
dude
you like heaven don't you mommy it's so
it almost sounds like he killed her yeah
it sounds like
he's happy she's dead
that's a one for me yeah that's the word
that might be the worst thing ever
uh what about this what is are we sure
this is real almost looks photoshop but
what is without oh jesus it's one of
these weird format ones
what is life
that's not how i hate hello
letters are formatted it what should
read what is without goal
life or i don't know what is without
life goal
what is life without goal but why is it
not plural what is life it is
superman superman yeah
geez man
somehow i have five different fonts in a
uh
what yeah i think it's a two word
sentence because
but be honest how much would you judge
somebody with this debt
you feel like dude you are the [ __ ]
worst
[Laughter]
oh yeah yay
i guess he's doing a film uh
role and the character had a tattoo and
he's like cool i'll just get the tattoo
instead of
uh doing a fake one and it's pretty
weird it's like an insane clown posse
with the mom and it says creeper and he
has kind of a cow hole going on too
it's pretty disgusting so i don't get
that because he's trying to pull off
like
a method staying here and get credits
for
like going the extra mile but i don't
it's not necessary no i mean
and that's so much there's like never
another great makeup artist of course
especially on a movie set of course
but i'm assuming he just really liked
the tattoo i don't think he would have
got it otherwise
creeper that's true he's gotta like it
but i mean he's a bizarre dude so
i have a feeling he just thinks cool
yeah
creeper bro that part better be [ __ ]
good
that better be a good ass movie bro
it's from a movie called the tax
collector
uh which is a david ayer movie i'm
seeing
uh who you know has made some good
movies
he did make a suicide squad though so
take from hunt take from that what you
will
so there you go so that one how do you
rate it
i mean that that one's the that one's
with the context and everything it's
it's not that big of a deal it's like a
probably a four or five
now if you had to take
that tattoo or ben affleck's the two
to get tatted on you i would get i would
definitely take ben
you would yes easily no fun yeah
no content agreed like easy
you i mean that one is so much worse
than bands
that one is so much worse than that yeah
and hold on did i just
did you just say that this is like a
four because i feel like this is the new
king
this is what i was referring to no it's
not that bad
what you just said you would take benz
over this that's why
yeah but i'm just saying in the context
of everything and who he
is that's not a tattoo i would want on
me
but look at those mickey hands it's got
mickey mouse is that
i always thought that ben's wasn't that
bad now that's not a tattoo i would ever
want to get
but i don't know that i can say that i
would prefer
bands if i had to pick one dude you want
a tattoo creeper
across your stomach instead of having a
phoenix that is like really
professionally colored and stuff it's a
no-brainer
i don't get it like a
[ __ ] mom cradling a insane clown
posse
this is creeper i mean that's just weird
either
it's weird but the phoenix one is so
cringe
dude okay if i saw the phoenix one i'd
be like wow that's
here's what i would think about the
person if i saw the phoenix tattoo
i'd be like that person is a little
or but but you know whatever it's not
they're a little nut and i mean a little
in the literal sense i guess yeah maybe
okay
but then if i saw shia labeouf tattoo i
would be like
i'm scared of that person no
that person is is is probably killed
somebody
no way that's what i would think
i don't think that dude it's so [ __ ]
weird
like bizarre it's beyond bizarre to me
that's like a psychotic thing to have on
your body
now the context of it makes it much
better like i said and i know he got it
for a movie and this and that and he's
kind of a weird guy and he's already got
tattoos all over him
but if i just saw him on the beach i'd
be like this guy is [ __ ]
okay demented this guy is totally
damaged
so yeah i would definitely take ben's no
question
and he's also got let's not forget he's
got a cow hole that's awful
what's with the mickey hands over his
[ __ ] [ __ ] stump belly button
and do not know exactly and you would
you would put that on you
uh i don't know
i mean he's running without his shirt
off he's proud of it he likes it yeah
okay let's move on i'm kind of with ila
a little bit you are
thank you i feel like i'm going
i i don't know i'm i just
the phoenix is like that guy
that i would not bro and shy is not it
is but i feel like i would prefer to be
that guy than that i think if you're shy
at least you look a little intimidating
i guess
the ben tattoo looks like you get you
get drunk at cabo wabo and
like it's like it never never um
got past 18 year olds and your ideas
like someone's step dad that they just
[ __ ] hate yeah
this gives me like i would never walk
with that on the street it's so big why
didn't he get it so
it like goes all the way down into it's
the worst it's still worth
it too that's why we got here if he
wasn't wearing pants the
phoenix like feathers would go into his
[ __ ] because look how long they are
maybe it does
we don't even know yeah maybe it does
that being said i feel like you needed a
refresher to see it again
it's worse than i remember but it's the
worst
that being said i don't know i don't
know i mean yeah it is
[ __ ] crazy it's so big i'm sorry but
this is like undateable
and like shia is like at least
i feel like maybe there's like some
substance to the guy seems kind of
interesting
compared to there's no substance to this
tattoo
at all yeah the other one has like story
like what's this about what's the
creeper mean why is there mickey hands
over your [ __ ]
a little more self-aware you know so
what if his story is like
the mickey hands is because i like to
[ __ ] kid
well i don't think it is oh well you
don't know
he also has what if uh ben affleck likes
to [ __ ]
phoenix phoenix isn't a real creature
well well what does it mean that he's
got mickey mouse hands over his crotch
and it says creeper so tell me what does
that mean
i feel like it's probably like ironic to
him
that it looks so bad
that's a big assumption
let's move on oh here he is before he
got it
ad break much better ad break ad break
ad break
everybody i've got an exciting
announcement to make
announcing our partnership with rich
wallets the futuristic wallet that is
here to
step up the game and make sure that your
wallet game is going to the next level
it comes with this beautiful tiny little
screwdriver which by itself
is worth the purchase i mean look at
this and then you can customize how
tight you want it
but it's a little tiny slick wallet it's
built like a freaking
rock your cards go in
about a bing you can fit up to eight
cards
boom you just did you just flash all
your cards no no
okay then you've got a money clip here
you put the dollars here
but it being holds like a holds like a
like a stupid holds like particles that
are attracted to each other
such a stupid [ __ ] analogy do you
have a better analogy
holds like uh
like we don't want to mention other
products
it it holds like a [ __ ]
probably don't want a curse either
already
holds like a [ __ ] uh you put the
cash you put the cards in there now this
is what's so great
it's slick it's light it safely secures
all your items
first of all nobody needs to be carrying
around chain oh like
we're over change in america we have
abandoned chain
so all that's left is this like little
tube put in a pocket
boom boom boom and you don't have a huge
cancerous
growth in your pocket where your wallet
used to be i mean i can't stand these
huge wallets it's it's unbelievable
yeah i gotta agree with you so i don't
know how guys do it because women have
purses usually i had to put my wallet in
my pocket
it would be a nightmare it is a
nightmare ridge
is the future zach tell me about you you
zach
you have a ridge go ahead i got it right
here
oh right there i i i love this wallet
it is fantastic it is not a it's not a
clunker
in the pocket it doesn't weigh you down
yeah conquer
all i can say it's compact stylish it's
fantastic
stylish do you feel cool when you pull
it out at like the store
oh hell yeah so many compliments on it
people look whoa what the [ __ ] is this
basically exactly exactly you get
compliments on it yeah
all the time nobody ever compliments
mine
you got to get that uh oh yours is you
got that high
notice factor yeah like i used the black
one
which is like low profile [ __ ]
but um this wallet is a game changer if
you're
especially if you're someone who's
bothered by like huge clunky wallets
game changer
okay get 10 off today with free
worldwide shipping
and returns by going to ridge.com h3
and use code
h3 one more time rage.cob slash h3 and
use code
h3 ela doesn't like when i burp
but i don't give a [ __ ] so
unprofessional
bye ridge please they're our only
sponsor
thank you ela i would like
for your consideration to submit what i
consider to be the best headline of
2020.
okay here's the headline amy schumer's
husband
chris fisher is uncircumcised
says pal jake gyllenhaal
uh evaluate that headline please either
if you would that is the best headline
of 2020.
um uh let me can i can i read you
yeah it says amy schumer's husband
chris fisher is uncircumcised and we
have the couple's pal
jake gyllenhaal to thank for letting us
know
why is that that's an article that is
why page six is that a gossip that's
just a gossip
that's right crazy yeah there you go
it's a tabloid yeah it's a tablet
but there you have it in case you were
wondering who the [ __ ] would click that
like okay tell me more about amy
schumer's husband's uncircumcised penis
because of jake gyllenhaal said who the
[ __ ] would click that
yeah well i just read the headline well
well not normally you just read an
excerpt i mean not normally
i wouldn't normally do that in a vacuum
they got you dude
ian you're the one that showed me this
article how did you find it
uh someone posted it on twitter and it
popped up they were like look how stupid
this is yeah
so well i guess it's gonna be maybe it
didn't work exactly they want you to be
like oh this is so stupid i gotta know
more
you know i feel like i feel i feel like
you're giving them too much credit
and you know sometimes it's just
i think somebody thought this was
interesting what i find more interesting
is that there's a
the reason that this was revealed is
because of a upcoming three-part
documentary
about amy schumer and her struggle with
hype hyperveilmesses
i'm sorry yeah i read about that's when
you get extreme nausea when you're
pregnant
which sounds miserable a three-part
documentary i don't want to watch one
part
just just her nauseous and puking all
the time yeah sounds pretty bad
you guys are hating right now for no
reason that's true a little bit
okay you guys will never have to be
pregnant
and we'll never have to be sick so
you're
gonna say so you're gonna watch all
three bars no
i expect you to watch all three parts
and report because yeah
i might though if i'm really desperate
which i am
there's nothing to watch right now dude
ellis says there's nothing to watch but
there's so much what you haven't watched
[ __ ] haven't watched
watchmen you haven't watched uh
[Laughter]
what's that show called that we liked on
hbo uh westworld
you haven't watched well westworld i
tried but the it got pretty annoying you
watched one episode yeah it wasn't the
best
i chose to skip i got pretty annoying
the new season
yeah yeah they kind of jumped the shark
i didn't like the second one either the
first one was pretty good but
i was still down with the second one but
like
it was getting questionable yeah they
jumped the shark yeah
they didn't stick mine out but okay uh
we're talking about amy schumer's
husband's uncircumcised penis can we
please stick to the topic at hand
so yeah he's uncircumcised fantastic
apparently he knows that because they've
been friends since they were kids so i
don't know and they were doing like
they were sword fighting as children or
something and yeah
there's kind of a so the real stories
that he was jake gyllenhaal was giving a
speech
at their wedding and he said in his
speech that
he's on just so you guys know everyone
knows he's uncircumcised
he's the only uncircumcised one in the
room or something like that
oh is everybody jewish yeah okay i don't
know
oh that's that how can he make that
assumption
they're all friends not everyone in the
room maybe the four of them
or like between the friends
for this conversation you know
dr disrespect has captured the
the speculation of the whole planet
what has happened to dr d
more clues have come out since we last
reported on it and
i mean i can't stop thinking about this
um and so i'm assuming that everybody is
really curious what's what's happened
here
we have a few little morsels of updates
i want to present to you guys and we can
also continue to speculate
but there's been no major news the only
news that's come out
is from a friend of his nick mercs
okay so the first one
comes as somebody donated under the name
doctor disrespect
let's watch the clip they gave him 50
bucks
i got a 50
he's donated to me before this is
exactly how he does it
he goes it's not the audio check the
records and pods
barely laying on a lounge chair right
now i hear everything you have three
ponytails still dripping the two-top
never slipping
twitchy's escape go question mark i
ain't even tripping
i think there's one oh no bro i don't
know
i don't know so
we don't know if it's real or not
although it's a good fake if it's a fake
but i didn't really follow what he meant
by uh this is exactly how he does it
i think what he meant is that he donated
before and that sounds like him or it
looks like him
he means doc's donated to him before and
he does it the same way
okay maybe the the way it appears
or the way it was phrasing his message
i'm not sure
a little uh limerick and i think he
always donates 50
as well i think i am i think it might be
that's all publicly known though that
would be pretty easy to fake
like if people know that that's how he
donates but i don't know
but well but he could easily look at the
email too right
they know each other so that's where
that's what comes in the next club but
couldn't he just
check the email address the donation
came through or is there like
i don't know if they come maybe through
one third party i mean all that stuff
and the fact that he knows it makes me
think it is him
i think it's him too but here watch this
this is the same guy
later tell us what happened at doc or we
will cancel you
i'll tell you in two months i'll tell
you in two months
dang you really think it's gonna take
that long that's what i know
two months bro on a stack though i've
been i've been twisted
so according to this guy
he says i know in two months
that that changes my whole analysis
frankly
to to what can only be the only option
that really remains is some kind of
contract dispute and
nda arbitration some kind of legal
which again it all sounds like it's not
that serious
not like what people are thinking is it
kind of serious
yeah i mean that really that goes
against for instance that uh that
slasher guys
uh you know claim that oh i know what it
is but uh i'm not touching this because
you know he made it sound like it's so
radioactive um
which i mean he could just be lying i
guess but everybody seemed to think that
that guy was credible so it's
very weird i don't know so can both be
true like if he had a metoo allegation
and then there they still i wonder they
still need to figure out this contract
i mean most contracts like that have a
clause for bad behavior where they can
just
can't sure but i don't know if because
like if i was dr disrespect and there's
allegations i would want to like that
right i'd be like well that's not true
you can't just drop me you owe me if
you're going to cancel my contract you
owe me the full payout
and so that makes sense to me that there
even if there was a metoo allegation
clearly something happened to cause
this there's clearly a big dispute going
on right now between twitch and dr
disrespect
that's the only explanation for the
silence there's some kind of
legal negotiating going on right now
so the question is really the same as
what has caused this
it could be a me too thing it could be
that it was looking to
join another platform i mean it could be
any it could be anything it doesn't
really change the speculation for me
if they could figure that out i guess i
just get the feeling from the way this
guy is
reacting that whatever doc did
is not that bad because this guy doesn't
seem disturbed no
he doesn't you're right as a friend yeah
he's that's true that's true
yeah god i just it's so weird it's so
weird
it's so weird why won't they say what it
is what's the big deal
but then so let's assume that that
message was real he says
twitch needs a scapegoat if that's
really doc what does that mean
they made an example of him and banned
him how are they going to make an
example and not even say what he's
banned for
yeah for example
yeah because rumor rumor has it
they were in a really big
exclusive agreement like millions of
dollars
yeah i think the production value of
that ad that they did with them really
points to that like they really pulled
out all the stops with that
and they wouldn't have done that unless
to them you know it was a
big investment that ad was awesome like
i would watch that on the super bowl and
be like super happy with that
right yeah it was like of that quality
well
so this resolves nothing and we learn
nothing in short
but actually it does suggest to a less
serious
crime to me that's the feeling i get but
yeah i don't know right it does it does
speak to a less serious crime
because it makes it seem like it's right
now it's just illegality and in two
months you'll be able to hear what
happened
i would be surprised if they could
resolve it in two in two months
because this [ __ ] i know it takes
forever
so could the original contract have just
had a uh
like a three-month nda period after
termination of the contract or something
like that
yeah could be for sure it could be
okay ian that was your time to shine
we're talking about kanye
exciting so ian um
i know you're a resident kanye superfan
so
let me ask you in before we get into the
whole
kind of meat and potatoes of this how
have your feelings on kanye changed over
the last couple of years
because when you started you were like
straight up super fan
ian and has your your status in the
community is kind of
wavered too hasn't it because you've
been kind of critical of him
uh i mean i i guess um
but my opinions have changed a bit
because it's becoming more
i was a fan of the music the clothes the
you know the performances and that's
kind of taking a big back seat
so you know i don't just
because it's him um
like what's going on now you know i i'm
i was originally here for the music
and uh there's not as much of that
i don't know right now so but
every kanye fan has to be a publicist
every time he does uh dramatic stuff
it's great do you feel like you're a
publicist right now
i get texts from what's going on what's
up with your guy
my parents text me what's happening i'm
like i don't know he has some
good albums i don't know about this do
you still spend time on the forums the
kanye forms
i mean for a lot of other stuff i'd you
know it's not just kanye i go online for
music stuff i'm definitely big in
talking to people about music in general
but
so okay so your opinions have changed a
little bit on kanye
he's he's announced he's running for
president
now i know that like the the community
is kind of torn
people didn't really know how to react
to this announcement
he tweeted out on july 4th uh of all
days
the uh the independence day we must now
realize the promise of america by
trusting god
unifying our vision and building our
future i am running for president of the
united states 2020 vision
now this
now this one obviously got a lot of
media attention and people are very torn
uh on how to feel about this now i'm
wondering how did the kanye community
feel about this
uh i guess they are very torn as well
but
at the same time uh this is probably the
fifth fifth or sixth time
where he has indicated his intent to run
for president
um which kanye fans know all those
so this isn't as shocking and we
a lot of people still think that this
won't happen i'm
including myself i don't expect him to
meet the deadline um
yeah i mean he said in that interview
that he's doing it to win
like everything else he does right or
something like that
yeah and he just put out a new song a
week ago um
you know his it's just his level of
promotion his media attention and then
the album comes out
yeah this is the cycle you've seen
before
yes now i so there was that feels to me
really shitty because
i don't know the selection is so serious
i feel like for me and probably for
everyone
and to play around with that for the end
goal of selling more
albums it's kind of do you see it that
way
ian as a as a kanye spokesperson
i don't know if he sees it as in those
terms like oh i'm going to tweet this
and then my sales are going to go up i
even think he made a comment like
i put my music out on streaming i don't
make anything of it
because they asked him in that forbes
interview
but i do think on some level he's aware
that this is brand building
yeah um and it may may not be as direct
as
this equals album sales right but it's
like
art build it up build it up smart
business man he knows what he's doing
yeah exactly so and he does it every
time
i i think he just does a thing and then
he uses that thing
to kind of fuel energy for creative
outlets
afterwards someone made a really good
comment
oh i think it was charlemagne actually i
agree with charlemagne in this
case um he said
like kanye has announced he wants to run
for president a bunch of times as you
pointed out
why is it now that the media is making
turning this into
into like a serious thing like he said
this so many times before
and nobody took him seriously but now
all of a sudden in 2020 in this huge
election that's so important
why is the media reporting it like it's
a serious thing
do you think that's a good uh insight or
not
yeah i i think um
i think that the way that they're
framing this whole thing is like
oh i'm just kind of a manic episode
is a little disingenuous and i think a
bit of a
bad faith attack on him because he has
been saying this stuff for
for a while um i don't think it's like
oh he's just he doesn't know what he's
saying he's talking and he's not aware
because he's having a bipolar episode i
think that's a little bit of a
cop-out really you think he's he really
intends to run for president
i think he i think he does
yes i don't think he will
but i think he wants to um
but he wants to do like 200 different
things at once that's how he is
he tweeted out last week i remember that
tweet he put out of all the
the the partnership with the gap yeah
and then a dr dre album and then a
cartoon series with
takashi murakami yeah and then a single
and like
maybe 75 of it actually came out
he does that all the time and then we
will never hear about it again
and i don't think it's because he
doesn't want to do those things i think
he just
spreads himself so thin and then just
picks and chooses and then things get
lost
i think this will be one of those things
the presidency
yeah well the truth is though as dance
pointed out is that
he's so late he's not on the ballot
on the biggest states already and even
if he
well he still hasn't filed any kind of
paperwork to show that he has
any kind of serious intent to run on
other states he hasn't missed the
deadline on
so it seems like it's definitely not
going to happen
and i find it strange that so many
people are taking this seriously i see
like especially on reddit like
very serious conversations about how
kanye is going to siphon votes off joe
biden and he's helping out
trump but to me it doesn't seem like so
like i'm just surprised that so many
people are taking
this seriously when he has not made even
the slightest
effort to actually get on the ballot
well he makes it sound like you did
i don't know what i i haven't followed
him
before or any of this stuff so i don't
know what it sounded like before when he
talked about presidency
but just in that interview he makes it
sound like he is serious
about it i don't know prior to this as
well
his um his he kept saying 2024.
um that was his thing and then it seems
like he pulled back on that
for some reason but i i i don't think
he's going to run right now but i do
think maybe this is him
testing the waters getting the
information for how he would have to do
it properly
next time then i could legitimately see
him doing it in four years from now
but i think yelat maybe answer your
question is that there are public
filing that you have to make in order to
get
on the ballot right right well she has
not done
so he's yeah he's originally on the
ballot
so so that's kind of the problem that's
why
that's why i don't really see it as a
serious thing but ian if you ran in four
years would you consider voting for him
no no what so so why is that why
wouldn't you vote for
your idol it doesn't align with my
ideals as a voter oh there you go
the vote for him would be uh uh
disingenuous
to myself i think well
um let me read you some of his platform
and then you can tell me which parts you
you maybe agree with or don't agree with
um his family says he's in the midst of
a bipolar
episode um which we
you touched on here are
some of his platform beliefs ian okay
on vaccines he says it's so many of our
children that are being vaccinated
and paralyzed so when they say the way
they're going to fix covet is with a
vaccine
i'm extremely cautious that's the mark
of the beast
they want to put chips inside of us they
want to do all kinds of things to make
it where we can't cross the gates of
heaven
i'm sorry when i say they the humans
that have the devil inside them
and the sad thing is that the saddest
thing is that we all won't make it to
heaven
that there'll be some of us that do not
make it next
question thoughts on his thoughts on
vaccine
[Laughter]
i just love the next question yeah
moving on
i've definitely thoroughly answered that
did he started with
um vaccines paralyze our kids to
if you get vaccines you can't go to
heaven
right yeah they're putting chips on you
yeah i mean yeah yeah not quite on board
with that
as you mentioned earlier the um
the uh reluctance towards vaccine
vaccines it's is becoming so widespread
very interesting yeah we saw we we
were looking at a a poll that said like
if a vaccine became available against
coronavirus only 50
of people said they would get it and you
need 90
at least for it to be effective
on abortion he says i am pro-life
because i am following the word of the
bible
has he always been religious he and or
is this a new meme
yeah but he i think he started
self-describing as born again
probably at the beginning of last year
like january of last year maybe a little
earlier
so that's the other thing when people
say oh
he's just these comments are coming
because he's in some episode
no this is a couple of these things
are linked to his new faith
and uh not coming out of an episode he's
been talking in these
ways for a while now well being pro-life
is obviously no surprise a lot of people
are pro-life on joe biden a lot of
people just like political parties they
feel all blacks have to be democrats
that man joe biden
said if you don't for me don't vote for
me then you are not black that's true he
did say that
uh well act like we didn't we all act
like we didn't hear that we act like we
didn't hear that man say that that man
said that
it's a wrap we're gonna walk all the
people jay-z said it best
for the other candidate i just
gracefully suggest y'all bow out
trump biden bow out
it's god's country we're doing
everything in service of god nobody but
god no
more i'm in service of our lord and
savior jesus christ
and i put everything i got on the line
to serve god
thoughts that's his that's what he
thinks about joe biden
yeah there's not much to say about it so
i think i think people are taking it
seriously it's not really serious
do you think he's having a manic episode
right now
or i mean i i don't know it's
it's it's so hard to play that game
yeah i mean how could you possibly know
i just see articles saying like
people like his family don't know
like how are people supposed to react to
this stuff like
i also supposed to take this thing
seriously or am i supposed to be worried
for him
like i just don't understand there's a
bit of mixed like for example this all
this coming from the article from forbes
which i feel like their presentation is
a little
i i don't know um
a little i'm skeptical of how they're
presenting this because they said this
is all taken from a four hour
recorded conversation and they took out
these bits
which totaled to about you know 45
seconds
right talking what happened the other
three hours and 59 minutes
why just these they haven't given us the
full cut they released
these like little audio pieces
about yesterday the day before um
where he freestyled a little bit during
the call
but they're kind of hiding it in the way
and then it's like presenting it like
they want you to think oh this dude's
losing his mind
but then also reporting on it as if he's
a serious candidate i don't know these
mixtapes
i had that same feeling ian because they
said we sat down with him for four hours
but the article does not say that much
it's like where is all of this content
and substance in a four-hour interview
would you just sit there quietly for
three and a half hours i don't get it
i mean the interviewer probably did
while he rambled for four hours but
surely there's more to say than that
um yeah i don't know definitely mixed
mixed messages there some and you also
made a really good point that they don't
the the interviewer never asks him about
his mental health
yet he continues to apply that he's
mentally unwell but he never outright
asks are you are you having a manic
episode right now
yeah i i i'm all i'm very confused by
all of this i really don't know what to
make it
make of it i really just kind of i hope
he's doing okay
i hope he uh doesn't run for president
and uh that's kind of it
that's kind of it really ian do you have
a statement you want to make about um
rapper jordan groggs oh yeah i put that
in there as a little thing i wanted to
say at the end
go ahead oh yeah i just uh
last week this this rapper passed away
named jordan groggs he was 32.
um he's in this group called uh injury
reserve
not super big and i didn't really see
that many people
talking about it and i really i'm a big
fan of this guy
so um i just kind of wanted to say uh
rest in peace to jordan and uh
he's super talented um he has an album
called floss
that i've listened to a bunch of times
i'd
suggest people want to check out if they
want to and
he has a wife and four kids and there's
a gofundme if you guys are interested so
just want to say that uh rest in peace
jordan grogs
how did uh how did he pass uh
they haven't revealed that i'm not sure
um
it's some medical thing they're keeping
private i don't know but uh
yeah it kind of came out of nowhere last
week wow that's rough with the kids
yeah yeah pretty heavy but
they were they were really kind of
building up a fan base too they're
really good it's a trio
uh rap trio so um oh that's a shame i'm
glad i'm glad you are uh
holding vigil for hemiann yeah just one
want to say that so and um anyways
um okay this is our final part of the
podcast and as you know i like to talk
about my
my friend my helper my best friend theme
star
oh yes game stars part of the show now
here's what i like to do with keemstar
some people are tired of me talking
about them some people
can't get enough dan dan yes dan doesn't
like me talking
you're not you're certainly not alone in
that i mean i've talked about them a lot
i'm i'm being i mean whatever we should
talk about this that you're about to
bring up because it it
yeah once again here's my philosophy is
that
obviously you could really nitpick kim's
starting a daily basis with the amount
of
dumb [ __ ] or hurtful toxic [ __ ] he does
but but then there's stuff that he does
that like
i feel like he should really be held
accountable for and the thing with
keemstar is that
nobody wants to talk about him
because it's just not worth getting into
it with keemstar
here's the enviable position that we
find ourselves in
is that keemstar has blocked us all on
twitter
of desperation he has nothing left to
say he has nothing left to unearth
he is done everything
and so like frankly i
totally understand other youtubers not
wanting to bring up keemstar
because dude he'll just he'll literally
go on a show and lie
about you and [ __ ] ruin you
so so that's a force to be reckoned with
right so here i want to talk about what
he did recently
we touched briefly on this in our last
episode
a twitch streamer named reckful
um tragically
passed on and
whenever something like this happens can
we just make a real
quick reference um because we talked
about it last week and none of us had
realized a fan pointed out in the
comments
that we actually had like a weird little
brush with him
several years ago where he was doing an
irl stream while he was visiting uh
barcelona spain
and ran into your parents so i remember
that
the real podcast will remember that yeah
we watched it on the show that's him
yeah i had no idea it was him i totally
remember it happening and i remember
even commenting like oh that he was so
nice and sweet like he was so respectful
and nice to my parents yeah
mm-hmm um yeah i learned that after we
did it was a really cool moment
i forgot that that was him so yeah
so he he tragically took his own life
and whenever this happens in the
community it's cause for a lot of
reflection
and thought people were on twitter
saying you know let's
we need to all be nicer to each other we
need to all be more
considerate of mental illness we need to
be more like
we have to be careful about the toxicity
amount the amount of toxicity
in these communities because it really
hurts people right
well um keemstar immediately
[Music]
immediately
starts attacking alinity who said that
she was suicidal on her stream
and he was like here's here's the clip
she's reacting to reckful's
passing uh now a lenny if you don't know
yeah we should just do a little
bit of ah a linearity's gotten tall she
gets a
she has a bad rap okay a long time ago
she like dmcad one of felix videos
and so she got a ton of [ __ ] from felix
and his fans
and then she also like was drunk on
stream one night and let her
cat have a lick of vodka and the cat
freaked out
and then another time she like i i don't
even want to really criticize her for
this one but
people gave her [ __ ] for throwing her
cat and to me i watched that video it
didn't really seem like a big deal she
had the cat that one was mild that one
wasn't yeah i mean cats are super nimble
and anyway it wasn't really like she
wasn't really a mean throw it was more
like you know
one of these and cats she obviously
loves her animals so that's not really a
question
um but she gets a bad reputation and a
lot of people dislike her on twitch
but but to me what um i noticed
when the whole doc thing was happening
and doc was trending number one
together with him alinity was trending
and it's like
that immediately just looked wrong to me
like the level of the volume of people
that were talking about her when she
actually had nothing to do with it
well that just gives you a glimpse to
what she gets the angle was that
oh uh doc gets banned before alinity
right but they don't know anybody
happened to doc right so it's kind of
weird no one even knows what happened to
him
and whatever happened with her that
blamed twitch then
if you have a problem with their
decision so why isn't twitch trending
why are you
not talking about them you're talking
about a person
yeah totally i mean keemstar and kind of
started this rumor
that she sleeps with twitch staff
members
and that's why she gets preferential
treatment there's no evidence
there's a horrible lie to say about her
yeah
and it really absolutely chauvinistic
it's totally chauvinistic and it totally
just
it it totally plays into this kind of uh
you know this whole narrative that uh
because there's
there's a strong amount of hate i think
that females in general get on twitch
because i think a lot of guys should be
like
you've got your titties out and you get
all these subs and viewers and
you're taking viewers away from real
good streamers and whatever because
i think that's just the culture of
twitch right so keemstar is playing into
this by making this
this um this fake story that she's
sleeping with twitch staff
which she's repeatedly said there's no
evidence and it's just not true
now so i think what you said is
is a really good point the fact that she
was immediately trending with doctors
disrespect because any time anyone gets
punished on twitch it's always like
a lindy did yes but this happened
and it's like she really is she gets
i when i saw that i was like dude you
guys need to [ __ ] leave this this
poor girl alone at this point
it doesn't i don't see hear a person
that like
hasn't changed is mistreating the cat
every time they're on stream or you know
nothing that will deserve the amount of
hate that she's getting right now
she also did this happened recently i
totally forgot where she actually showed
her tit
okay and people were like oh banner
like she was dancing and she lifted up
her over shirt and her tick came out
like for a second
totally accidental but like nudity stick
strictly prohibited so i was like
battling she's [ __ ] ah
you got a banner she showed her too and
i think they did suspend her or
something
i don't remember but people hate her
guts
and that's like a mistake again yeah it
was a mistake
but anyway i mean twitch is pretty
hardcore about
even accidental nudity so they they
suspended her
they did suspend her for that well then
there you go i mean but people
say there's a double standard i don't
know i'm not i'm not really into that
i'm not into the whole thing too much
either
i'm just saying from from my point of
view of watching it from the side
i can tell very clearly that there was
something wrong happening here
towards her right there right that's
right and so anyway she
she in response to what's going on with
with what happened to reckful
made a video speaking up about you know
basically
her the amount of harassment she has
continued to get
for years listen i i just want to talk
to you guys about something
and i think like i promised to myself
throughout everything that's happened
that i would never appear weak
that i would always stay strong
and not show people how much their words
hurt me
but i can't do that anymore
because you guys need to know
that the [ __ ] you guys do and the [ __ ]
you guys say
really affects people okay
like
you guys have no idea how many times
i wanted to kill myself
how many times i've spent
my entire night trying to figure out
how i was gonna end my life
and i just want you guys to know
i just want you guys to know that it's
really
serious that
you guys can't just like send hordes of
hate
towards somebody without it having an
effect on a person
okay i might be able
to cope with it or i might just be
really weak
and not be able to
go through with the things that i've
wanted to do in the past
but sometimes i feel
like i would rather
be in jail than
have to deal with so many people
saying so many mean things okay i think
in her case it's just like the end
it's like it's okay to make a mistake
and get criticized but it's like people
do not ever let it go and as someone
who's gotten
as much [ __ ] as anybody on the internet
i can say there were times
when it felt like there's no other
explanation for the amount
of and the intensity of the hate that
i'm getting
other than the fact i feel like they
want me to die they want me to kill
myself
no i was never suicidal but like it felt
like but
like it just feels so bad and i and i
really felt like they want me
to [ __ ] kill myself there's no
explanation for this relentless
this relent just it is just relentless
so she's getting it bad really bad
so anyway keemstar sees this now this is
this is when everybody is like kumbaya
right
and everyone's like you know what let's
take a step back let's think about what
we're doing
now keemstar sees this video and his
immediate
response is to start calling her a liar
that she's fake crying here let me read
you his tweets this is immediately dude
right after this guy
uh committed suicide he says doctor
disrespect
trending with alinity hmm dear and then
of course he tags her because that's
that's his thing he needs to harass
them directly i think he truly gets
satisfaction
from knowing that he's tormenting her
she he knows that she's
not in a position to battle him um
she says derelinity are you the reason
dr disrespect is banned
asking for a friend what that is just so
mean spirited and that's it there is no
reason for that tweet other than
to just ruin her day and especially to
tag her
right there isn't like even
there is no excuse it's just evil
keemstar says oh you know what
ninja and elindidy got into a fight on
twitter apparently
and they all felt bad and erased their
tweets and apologize to each other which
i thought was cool
keemstar responded to ninja ninja said i
kept looking back at the tweet and
saying i wouldn't have sent that if i
wasn't a little tilted i apologize and
then he tagged her alinity and then
keemstar responded said
why she threw her cat and fed it vodka
and the reason why people
still bring it up is because we love
pets she was never punished by twitch
because of those two things you can't
let it go when you have a list of like
dude one thousand the totality of [ __ ]
you have done is in [ __ ] measurable
oh my god what have you done throw her
cat and fed it vodka
like dude those are forgivable things
that is really not a baby she has
apologized for it
already dude you [ __ ] falsely accused
tony of being a pedophile
twice and still have never apologized
for the second time
i mean you are a piece of [ __ ] bro oh
what's it garbage
garbage
um so then if we go back
let's see he says someone said after a
streamer was bullied by the community to
the point where he killed himself
do you not think that then less than a
day later you could stop for a while
with the constant abuse thrown around
yes she was never punished because they
investigated it someone said and he
responded he quote tweeted it
and said do you think it's any
coincidence that alinidy started crying
on stream
about being bullied yesterday uh yeah
maybe she was upset
like like is that finished it's almost
like the perfect timing right after a
tragedy
some may say straight up manipulation
excuse me it sounds like you're telling
us how your brain is thinking this is
just so
evil this is so exciting no okay
this is how people with emotions react
to someone killing themselves
dude the fact she's crying about being
bullied the day after somebody killed
themselves and she
and she if she's not allowed to cry
unless she's manipulating people
how about you just shut the [ __ ] up for
one day bro
and by the way this tweet has 10 000
likes so like this isn't just him
screaming into a void he's stirring up a
lot of [ __ ] for her
when she's trying to move past this
right
he's he's he's seen the video and he's
and he's saying i'm not gonna let you
move past this i'm gonna do everything
my power she said
i've been suicidal and keemstar's
response to that is
i'm gonna do everything my power
essentially
like i'm i'm reading between the lines
here and i'm not sure even if keemstar
is
this like conscious of what he's doing
but what he's doing is saying
i want you to i want to push you more
towards that
well even if he's not understanding that
he's doing that that is what
that's what he's doing she says i've
been suicidal from the harassment and
keemstar says i'm on
i want i want to keep pushing you
towards that or that's the act
i don't know what his motivation is but
that's his what his action is doing
right that's his response
so i mean what the [ __ ] dude i mean this
guy is sick minded he's dang this is my
point about keemstar he's dead
he's dangerous i just and this is
after by the way all the [ __ ] he caught
and the whole dialogue around ediker
right
i feel like for the longest time for the
longest time i used to just
just try to stay out of it because
following him and the drama that he's in
it's endless it's every week there's
someone else
he's always in a fight with someone
there's always something going on you
can't even follow it without going crazy
but i feel like i'm at the point where
i've changed my mind
and i feel like there's a responsibility
on everyone
to call it out when he's doing this
stuff because
yes erica happened no one is saying
keemstar killed erika
but he was involved in the in a really
really bad situation he was involved in
it
and now reckful died
in a really bad situation and everyone
is
i i feel like i can't just sit and just
watch him do this to people
yeah i just can't and i don't care what
elinated did okay so she did
two bad things to her cat that are
really like
it's a mistake she moved on she
apologized she can grow up and not do it
again like let's put it in perspective
totally i i kind of i'm i have like a
massive disappointment with the
community to be honest because
nobody will touch this but it's actually
so
[ __ ] up and dangerous what he's doing
yeah like
nobody will touch this nobody will
[ __ ] touch
this you know everybody when i made a
video about keemstar
every commentary channel was so quick
and fast to make a video about how i
can't believe ethan called out g-fuel
but when keemstar is pushing alina when
he's pushing
a person who said she's been suicidal
and he's continuing
to harass her in response to that and
nobody's willing to speak up about that
i just i find the whole thing just
disturbing frankly
he goes on he keeps tweeting about he
says twitch community reminds me of a
cult
i don't really think of any of these
individual people have individual
thoughts or opinions because he was
getting [ __ ]
for for what he was saying about
felinity they just kind of seem like
robots that all follow follow follow
the same people bowling olynyk now want
to bully anyone that don't forgive her
oh so you're not one of them people
bullying olindi
right i'm so shocked that keemstar sees
a group of people as not human and
having no emotions
right he says i've lost so much respect
for these streamers very low iq people
anyway so elenity responds and really in
just kind of
the most sincere way possible oh i can't
look at it because
she made her tweets private because
she's getting harassed so much
that's crazy she made her twitter
private
hang on i gotta go to my own twitter
because we follow each other
that's crazy that your [ __ ] is private
dude
i wonder i wonder who caused that oh
yeah i want to
how did you pull it up because i'm
logged into my twitter
so she just quote tweeted his his tweet
about him saying
that um she's fake crying and she said
please [ __ ] stop i can't do this
anymore
and a lot of people rallied behind her a
lot of support her tweet got 57 000
likes 2000 retweets
and a lot of people were were showing
support you know
and um he of course he didn't even erase
the tweets they're still up you know
he didn't apologize he didn't really
back down at all
his response was that everybody's low iq
um she actually even dm to me people
started asking me questions about how to
deal with keemstar i'm like dude don't
you understand
there's no [ __ ] way to deal with
keemstar she's like how do i get him to
stop to leave me alone she said how do i
get him to leave me alone
this happened just a few days ago i
asked her i asked her if i could share
the contents of this conversation she
said yes but i was like
look ultimately um
that's how that's like starting actually
there isn't really any legal thing you
can do
and and and i mean as like you can make
a video and defend yourself that's
ultimately what i had to do
but then she goes like i can't i just i
don't have the energy i don't have
i think that i don't have the will to
yeah to take on that battle i mean
that's what we were
for a long time too until we decided to
make those videos i had to they they put
me in a corner i couldn't
yeah like the amount of [ __ ] and [ __ ]
lies and [ __ ] that was being said
about me
i literally was like fight fight or die
and he put me in that corner and so
and so she she doesn't feel that she's
up to like
challenging him and i don't blame her at
all i mean it's a it's a [ __ ] show she
just wants to be left alone
so i told her honestly i i i really
don't have a good solution for you
you either just got to address it or
ignore it because there's really no
there
really nothing else you can say or do
oh and then there's this other thing
that keemstar's been doing
so he was sending pictures of horses to
me to make fun of
hila for a long time until um
until we called him out for so much that
he stopped i think
also no one cared you guys well he never
blocked ela until recently
right right right but um well the
responses were so confused
people were just like what are you even
on about even his followers
yeah he just looked like he was insane
well he's so there's this guy starkiller
on youtube who is a supporter of ours
he made a video defending me on goku
narrows
video like you know years ago when it
first happened
and so like he he's known to be a fan of
ours and he doesn't like keemstar
but he's a very small channel he had he
has at the time like 1500
followers on twitter and keemstar
goes out of his way this account with
1500 followers
and he starts tweeting pictures of the
wicked witch
directly to him presumably
to make fun of the way his wife looks
now the reason he's bringing up the
wicked wish thing is because
starkiller told me that when they were
on stream his wife joked that she looked
like a witch
the day before and so he starts tweeting
pictures of
witches it's a starkiller an account
with 1500.
once again to start making fun of his
wife's appearance now i ask
what keemstar clearly has a pro an issue
with winning
so insane i mean what is his problem
with women
i found the fact that he went after her
so disturbing
because i i in my mind i was like at
least like
when he goes after me i've also talked
[ __ ] about him
and i'm also like more involved in the
topic but
why are you going after this guy's wife
what do you find it weird too that like
he attacks you and her
you're both two objectively beautiful
women to try to call ugly yes she's very
beautiful
it's so stupid so
anyway he continues to do it for like i
mean he did it for days dude he did it
for like a week straight and then you
want to know how petty he is
he would he would send the tweet of the
witch to him
and then immediately block him so he
couldn't respond
and then the next day he would unblock
him send the picture to the witch
and then block him immediately so he
couldn't respond this guy
is spending this much time to harass a
dude with 1500 followers
for whose crime was simply being a fan
of ours
not just that i mean he's criticized
game store too
here's a picture of the wicked witch
again now he starts tweeting pictures of
alice in wonderland the witch
munchkins people are like dude you're
like [ __ ] five two
um it just gets super weird so ila
decided to clap
the [ __ ] back and dunk on this
[ __ ] and i think that keemstar
really does embody the true definition
of a [ __ ] as eli points out she says do
you want to know what a [ __ ] is
b being keemstar with 2.8 million
followers
i is mock is tweeting at starkiller with
1500 followers
t to mock his wife's looks see
comparing her to a witch h ha ha it got
two likes first we got two [ __ ] likes
and thank you and i took the kim star
approach i dedicated to him um
i learned it from what he was doing to
star kayla i
unblocked him i tweeted at him and then
i blocked him again
and then in return he blocked me he
blocked you within like two seconds
two seconds two seconds or so right
after this to it came out
and that was great i love it
oh this was funny someone picked showed
a picture of keemstar with jeffrey
epstein
yeah is this real i was like hold on let
me report it and find out afterwards
yeah so ela dunked on keemstar
never apologized never anything he just
started blocking people
um again it's just the guy is
i mean look dude this is why i keep
talking about him that that [ __ ] is all
just like stupid petty crap
but the stuff about alinity is is deeply
disturbing i mean
there's every week something disturbing
like just a week ago
it was making really awful comments
about someone's
sexual assault story on twitter and the
context of this
the girl that um she made
like one of those long tweets and he
basically
resp he was talking about it in a tweet
without saying her name
as if that matters like i found it in
two seconds
um that basically
he's super upset
uh if the girl doesn't say
no then how am i supposed to know that
i'm like assaulting her
is his his point because she froze in
the moment
in her story she didn't excuse me she
didn't explicitly
say no but she in her story she was
laying there crying if i recall
her story is long too and he it's the
one that he said that he didn't read the
whole thing
he stopped because he was like oh she
the whole story has a lot more to it she
doesn't say at the end look at this guy
rape with me let's cancel him
he's her friend it's a little more
complicated than that
she never said he raped her goes if
she's crying
while i'm having sex with her that's not
no
those are tears of joy
yeah tears are generally you should
pause and see what's up if you see two
i don't know i i i would be crying if
keemstar was having sex with me
i would find a way to live my body
got yeah poor anyway anyway keemstar is
a dangerous man
i don't i think he is a toxic he is an
unquestionable
stain on this community and he will
continue to be a dangerous stain he's
incapable of changing
and it's only a matter of time before he
does something so horribly inconceivable
like that we'll all wonder why we
allowed it to go on for so long
that's that's that's my opinion and i
think he's a ticking time bomb it's just
a matter of time
before another tony another etiquette
another whatever this this this happens
and we all go oh it is keemstar's fault
it is a pattern of events this isn't you
know what i mean he
is actually willing to push people to
the limits of their
tolerances currently yeah currently
so anyway that's keemstar for you baby
everybody get excited for keemstar
good luck ethan because you're gonna
[ __ ] need it
whoa why what did i do h3h3
is [ __ ] innocent oh thank you
you're a [ __ ] hypocrite well which is
it am i everybody on my incident good
luck ethan cause you're gonna [ __ ]
need it remember when he ended his video
about me with a
literal threat
[Laughter]
garbage garbage do i have that sound
bite i don't you're a [ __ ] hypocrite
good luck garbage
anyway guys that's all the show we have
today i like to leave you on a taste of
keemstar
we should have a segment name for our
keemstar once a taste of keemstar
i was enjoying calling him cumstar i
thought that was funny
but it doesn't really happen no it's not
that good yeah it doesn't have a deeper
meaning [ __ ] star
[ __ ] star [ __ ] stain
i don't know why i like come star you
know the have you seen these contributes
that people do yes of course i have that
[ __ ] is so
foul who hasn't garbage well these guys
i remember i was talking with them and
they said they haven't seen it you guys
saw the contributes of keemstar
i i i think i've still managed to avoid
that you may have not been it was mostly
around the time
uh of the content cost i saw it a couple
days ago you guys
had like 100 likes it's so gross
how could anyone bust on that photo dude
i feel like i would have to like cut my
dick off
somehow i've managed to escape that i
did uh uh like a week ago
for the first time see the infamous um
leafy's [ __ ] picture
oh leafy tweeted it out he did yeah what
oh gross
yeah it was [ __ ] horrific it was so
disturbing
i i guess he's trying to own it you know
what i mean uh
huh cool okay but
good point
but it's just shocking to see yeah yeah
it's so graphic it's like he's gay his
[ __ ] is gaping open like oh yeah
yeah it was worse than like it had been
described to me i mean
it's pretty shocking it's like a dude
holding his [ __ ] open for you
and you can see his nuts and his dick
flopping down and he's
i mean he's opening his [ __ ] for you
to look at that's what it is that's the
photo
yeah it's so good oh
then wow um
oh there it is yeah eel is looking at it
right now
it's [ __ ] horrific i mean who the
it was quite um it looked quite inflamed
or like uh maybe not flames but well it
looks like
they're red it it it does not look uh
hemorrhoids
happy yeah no that that's an [ __ ] of
someone who gets pounded
i mean i'm just that's what it looks
like to me
maybe i don't know i don't know
but i've gone years uh without seeing
that somehow but um
somebody something judged me with it
yeah they got me
they got me well anyway i mean it's it's
i think it's great that he's tweeting it
out and he's owning it
nothing wrong with taking nudes and for
the record
shame on whoever leaked that that's just
that's not cool
i mean that's a i've i mean i've taken
pictures of my [ __ ] i wouldn't want
that to be leaked
[Laughter]
that's the last place i want to see i
mean his ass was hairless you wouldn't
realize my ass was like
they're at the crack you stop being able
to see any details because there's just
a lot of hair
right like you said that nobody wants to
see that because it's hairy i
i feel like in a way that's almost
better because at least it's being
scared no no no you don't want yeah i
mean no the hair is better than
just the straight right that's right
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah
because the way he presents himself like
he doesn't leave anything to imagination
it's just
everything's out there bro it's wild and
it's like gaping crazy
can we stop describing yeah probably
sure i mean you just pulled up a photo
of it why'd you do that
because you said it tweeted it out i was
curious
curious how dude you've never seen it
before you had seen it before
i wasn't sure but i was curious about
the tweet
he said who uploaded a picture of
leafy's news
yeah it had a noticeably less engagement
than his other tweets i will say
shocking well that's really all there is
to it i mean uh
you know
it's friday my dudes uh help is almost
over there's about 15 days left
we'll have given out 100 billion dollars
wow you know what's crazy jeff bezos
could give out 100 billion i said that
like
hyperbolically like nobody could give
out that much money jeff bezos could
give out a hundred billion dollars
so good second building below the uh 100
mark didn't he no jeff is actually his
wealth is way up he's at 180 now
from the pandemic oh you're right the
pandemic has
i think he's made like 30 billion
dollars since the pandemic started um
excuse me ethan not all of that is in
liquid assets uh
obviously you don't know how
billionaires operate
that's true it's probably all stock it's
probably 90
stock uh but i mean
you know still he's probably he's
earning like crazy dividends
that's a lot of cheese it's a lot of
cheddar like how much does it get in
dividends from every
time they pay out it's gotta be [ __ ]
crazy
180 billion yeah
that's a lot of two-ply kirkland two-ply
that's a lot of two players
zach how much kirkland two play can you
buy with 180 billion a lot of curriculum
to play
there's a lot of two blocks man kirkland
yo speaking of two-ply and just our last
episode
just a quick note um you know i was uh
pushing back pretty hard on the whole um
napoleon swam back to europe
discussion you know i thought that was
um that was pretty far-fetched
but a very uh insightful commenter on
the last episode did point out
he pulled it up on google maps and there
is a series of small islands between
uh elba and mainland europe that means
that uh the furthest you would have to
swim at a time is about four miles
which is reasonable so what i'm trying
to say is i think i'm convinced i think
napoleon swim back to europe
yeah you got me and have you found any
literature any literature at all that
supports that
no nothing i believe
but you know what they're they're
keeping the wall over our eyes man yeah
they don't want us to know he's swimming
okay so here's kirkland two-ply
kirkland two-ply write this down 30
rolls
is 20 what am i writing it down for so
hang on
30 rolls is 20 dollars so
if you have 180 billion
so that's yeah you could get uh nine
uh divided by twenty nine billion uh so
you could buy thirty it's not a kirkland
two play
yeah you could wait hang on is that
right you could buy
you'd have to multiply by thirty so it's
uh nine billion
right so you would have nine and thirty
packs hold on which is really
two hundred and seventy billion rolls of
toilet paper wow
two nine really it's two ply so you
could double that really
if you really want to get crazy you
could pull the two-ply apart and get
two sheets so you have yeah
270 billion rolls right there
or sheets rather no rolls right well
hold on though because if you
even you could take this further because
each one has 425 sheets
so if you take 270 billion
right yeah and times it by 425
yeah then you're looking at you can't
even express this number
it's so big it's scientific notation
it says 1.1475 e plus 14.
oh my god that's a lot of kirkland that
would be the name of uh elon musk
and then again because it's two ply you
got to double that final number so let
me times it by
could theoretically pull the two sheets
apart to to get even more one player
well that wouldn't be two player that'd
be one play but if you if you're right
yeah
you get you guys if you want a lot of
sheets you can floor you can four
play that as well you can stack how can
you four
oh yeah sure of course you could that
would be you divide by two if you wanted
a four plot
but that gets them in a whole new
territory because if i
if i divide this by four that should
give me the the four ply number
which would be five uh point seven three
seven five
e plus 13. kirkland
yeah baby all right well jeff bezos we
have a new project for you
[Laughter]
all right that's about it eh cheers
cheers to that and in like two years
time i want to show you that deleted
ethan bradberry prank
that he sent us that was too [ __ ] up
we couldn't show it
oh yeah if we showed that i think he
would be arrested i'm serious
that's the best i actually think you
would be able to need to wait ten years
statute of limitations five years i
think oh but
i think once the virus once the viruses
behind us then people will
and nobody will care um
but that might be fun that might be five
years for all i
dude it was crazy we said we just told
ethan bradbury
go on the street i think you would be
funny man on the street
can you just go and like ask people
questions about the coronavirus and see
what they have to say
and he goes and does this crazy [ __ ]
prank where
he's like he's pretending he has corona
virus
but we're not we must have described it
before i don't think we did
he's he's interviewing yeah you
described it oh we did okay he goes and
he's pretending that he has coronavirus
and he's
coughing and [ __ ] and it's like dude no
you can't do that
yeah that was at the very beginning
though of it to be
at least give him some benefit of the
doubt before lockdown yeah that was
before lockdown so people were kind of
like uh what is this we don't really
know what this is but we're kind of
scared of it
but people actually get arrested for
that now coughing on people and [ __ ]
he didn't cough on anyone like in that
way but
god all glory to ethan bradberry
blood of the lamb blood of the lamb to
ethan bradberry
can we wrap this up i mean what is this
you're the one
extending uh
uh is that you or the soundbite zack
that's the
soundbite like that yeah i thought it
was zack
yeah weird
no that that is definitely not me by the
blood of the lamb
hello oh i hit demon but it doesn't do
anything
on this i guess can you do unique new
york unique
unique new york unique new york unique
new york
unique new york new unique new york
unique new york unique new york
unique new york unique new york new
unique new york new york new york
unique new york new unique new york new
york new york
new year new york new year new york new
york new york
what am i saying wrong you're saying new
week new york
i don't know what it is about those
works but they really slipped me up
unique new york unique new york unique
new york new unique new york
unique new york it's so hard
all right this is uh let's go let's just
help all go have a good weekend all
right that's all i want from you guys
dan today's dan's 30 year anniversary
30. three three of a conversation about
uh everyone should uh
evaluate we need to evaluate that hello
then this is your evaluation
right now maybe we could do this off the
air
zach and do you have any evaluation
comments for dan
nothing but positivity good oh thank you
jack
love that man i mean his his chip
etiquette is a little oh we're gonna
have to talk about the chips that's
true just last week
what yeah you were chewing up twitter oh
yeah yeah it was also
all toy okay you know i'm gonna have
nice would have to make rules for every
individual
item yeah exactly you can't just like it
ban the chewing that would be
irresponsible you gotta eat
man's gotta eat well let's go ahead and
have a great weekend everyone all right
she's good all right all right
tata tatty
[Music]
hey